No,
that the snake is
utilize conceptually and metaphorically
as representation of transformation,
right?
Because the snake is something that can
shed its skin and be reborn.
We know that a snake is something that's
innately attractive and terrifying human
beings and other primates,
so that if you come across a snake,
you're likely to be at least startled,
if not horrified by it,
but also attracted to it in a way that
is underneath your voluntary
consciousness,
right?
Because snakes attract orienting reflex
isn't they activate the systems
underneath your consciousness that
actually govern the structure of that
consciousness.
We know that the snake can be well
represented as well as internal chaos.
So imagine this,
imagine that it's not unreasonable for a
self conscious mind searching for a mode
of self representation to remark on the
parallels between the structure of the
snake and the spine and the brain.
Given that a snake is essentially a
spine with a brain.
And then imagine as well that the most
archaic aspects of our nervous system,
those that govern novelty and orienting
and anxiety responses are in fact
precisely those that were described by
Mclean as nested inside the reptilian
brain.
And then imagine along with the Hindu
Yoga,
is that the purpose of Kundalini Yoga is
to activate the circuitry that's
associated with that snake,
so to speak,
to produce a permanent state of alert
wakefulness.
It's associated with consciousness.
Ooh,
so imagine this,
imagine an animal like like a zebra
grazing mindlessly in the herd with no
consciousness whatsoever.
And then imagine it's relatively
undeveloped cortical structures
activated suddenly by the movement of a
lion off in the perimeter.
And then imagine for that brief moment
that thawed zebra is actually conscious,
a state that requires a tremendous
amount of energy on difficult to
maintain,
but because the threat and the
uncertainty manifest itself within the
zebras mode of consciousness,
it wakes momentarily.
And then imagine that human beings are
like that.
Zebra always because we've become self
conscious because we know that the
unknown is around us all the time.
Even when we think we're safe,
we're never safe.
Imagine that.
The reason we're so conscious is because
as a consequence of our discovery of the
possibility of our own mortality,
all of this underlying circuitry that in
other animals is only apparent when
they're startled or afraid or interested
or curious.
In human beings.
It's on all the time.
And that's what makes us conscious.
And the reason for that is because we
developed enough cortical elaboration to
note that we're always threatened by
everything that's around us.
And then imagine that,
well,
that's pretty awful,
isn't it?
Because it's at the basis of all our
innate existential,
but then imagine as well that without
that terror pushing us forward and and
our constant reference to the dangerous
aspect of the unknown,
we would have never been motivated to
produce the kind of societies that we've
produced,
which are essentially very remarkably
elaborated devices that enable us to
find some protection from that unknown
and to manipulate,
manipulate it effectively.
And then remembering that story we will
return to genesis young says the snake,
his was regarded by early gnostic
Christians as a kind of daddy who's
faculties were more developed and
advanced than the original daddy that
actually structured the world.
The idea there being that the world
initially was a pretty dismal place.
Everyone wasn't conscious.
We all existed at the level of the
animal and then the snake came along and
said,
wake up,
wake up.
And the movement from that state of
unself consciousness paradise to this
profane state of awakening can be
regarded not so much as a descent,
but as an asset of sorts,
even though a painful one.
And then you have your,
at this commentary from Mephistopheles,
his representation of Satan and his
capacity for temptation,
who says,
follow the adage of my cousin's snake
from dreams of God.
Like knowledge.
You will wake to fear in which your very
soul shell quake a statement associating
the human tendency to attribute to all
revolutionary sources of new
information,
uh,
kind of demonic being.
And then you have the problem of the
woman.
Now we know that within the context of
the Judeo Christian tradition,
women have unduly suffered for their
role and tempting humanity in the
embodied form of Adam towards higher
order self consciousness.
And then you think,
well,
let's just take a look at how human
beings and their mating relationships
differ from those of other animals like
chimpanzees to whom we are very closely,
genetically related.
And if you look at the mating strategies
of female chimpanzees,
you see that they really don't care who
they sleep with,
so to speak.
Any old chimpanzee will do.
Now the last dominant male chimps tend
to be chased away by the more dominant
male chimps.
But if a female and less dominant chimp
can get the hell away from the watchful
gaze of the dominance hierarchy,
they're perfectly happy to mate.
Human females are not like that.
There is selective matters,
and there's a tremendous body of
evolutionary psychological information
that suggests that although both genders
value intelligence and physical
appearance,
females value the ability to attain
dominance,
hierarchy status in men far than men,
admire the ability to attain dominant
status in women,
which is to say that men don't care what
a woman has with regards to potential
for attaining status.
Whereas with women,
it's one of the strong determinants of
mating preference.
So Len,
let's say,
look,
we don't know why the hell our cortex is
expanded so rapidly,
somewhere between five and 3 million
years ago.
Let's offer this as a hypothesis.
The women started to get choosy,
and because they were so damn
complicated,
the whole human species had to
exaggerate it's cortical growth prior to
any even use for that cortical growth,
just so that the men had an even hand in
the competition,
right?
So women put tremendous selection
pressure on the human being to develop
tremendous,
tremendous cortical expansion.
Now,
we already know that from a mythological
perspective,
that women are frequently casting to the
same conceptual domain,
the temptress domain as the benevolent
aspect of the unknown.
And we know as well from representations
of hero mythology that it is the
individual who goes out to confront
chaos,
who's most likely to free from the
Dragon,
not only treasured,
but a virgin,
say in the case of mythological
representations like Saint George and
the Dragon.